well
hello, how are you, greets héctor mejía
with his brief informative for today,
wednesday, february 24, the
henderson police are on the trail
of a suspect who tried to steal a
vehicle and killed a person, it happened
yesterday near the transmitter, according to the
authorities, on  suspect fled the
scene after attempting to steal a car
and run over someone else
if you are 65 or older and live in
our ranks you can sign up for
the coronavirus vaccine
the city says a limited number
of people will be able to make an appointment for
receive the first dose as of today you
should visit the page of ax nlb
dotcom
and cis employees and here they prepare
for the great return to school
starting Monday students will find new
signs to keep their distance in
addition there are fewer desks per classroom there is
a guide  given by the
district for all schools in the
valley and now we turn to the
weather forecast today we will have  On a hot sunny day
we will hit 70 in the
afternoon however there is a
wind alert for all of southern nevada
starting at noon have a
great day I am hector mejía and this
was your brief informative on spanish ginseng
[Music]